[Music]
my name is Susie and I will be your host
in this episode I am joined this
afternoon by the fluff of nightmares
lady White Rabbit hey guys I know of an
absent a lot on my channel but I promise
the big video is coming in just a week
and it'll be worth the wait so just stay
tuned we are also joined tonight by the
third voice of death mortis media hey
guys my latest video may or may not be
about bacon so you should go to my
channel to find out vegans beware and we
have our first ever guest on the show
Amy from what a guts and social
commentary hi guys I will be back on
schedule within a week or two hopefully
you're listening to episode 4 of the
dead stream so it's October what are you
guys is plans for Halloween and what
have you done so far well my big video
coming up will be the sequel of Braska
it'll be out hopefully on Monday as I
have scheduled the audio is now done so
I'm just working on visuals and music
and then hopefully I'll be done within
the next couple of days here and that oh
oh that's good to hear because I
remember last time you're saying that
you hated your voice by the end of yeah
yeah absolutely hate it even more now so
I'm sick of hearing about Frasca and I
wanted to stop but it's gonna be great
it's not just any plans for stuff that
you're doing
in October outside of the channel I will
be moving next week not very far away
but hopefully it will result in better
internet connection so if I start
cutting out here it's because my
Internet's terrible so this will be the
last time we have to deal with it yeah
what about you Mart
let's see anything channel wise not
really just trying to do longer videos
for all you love
followers who like those longer 40-ish
minute videos so that Halloween I am
going to Transylvania to see count
Dracula's castle which should be very
interesting no it's actually it's not on
Halloween it's too expensive it's a lil
go after but nonetheless I think it's
gonna be awesome
that's really cool so is there like a
guided tour or do you just go and
explore the castle how does that work
how abut well I booked their flights but
I haven't booked the castle tour yet I'm
sure there'll be a guided tour so you
know what I might even do a special
video just about that see ya nice and
what about you blood I am well what's
going on with the channel will be
discussed in a minute but I am streaming
tomorrow to benefit scarce that care
which is a horror based charity so
that's kind of my big Halloween several
celebration and there's nothing in it
for that oh yeah that's great thank you
and mortis and White Rabbit if you'd
like to join in please feel great nice
yeah and I believe the plan for
Halloween is us and two other houses are
going to do a joint decorating venture
and pop out at children nice I've always
wanted to do that like set up an actual
haunted house in my house I couldn't do
it right now because I live in an
apartment but I think that's such a cool
idea there actually was a house in our
neighborhood that used to do that and
they had a prize system if you got to
their door you get like a fun sized if
you got all the way to the back though
they give you a king sized that's oh no
nice you just had to get through a
zombie and be chased by Leatherface
usual yes
there's the costumes that you're gonna
use this year as well I'm doing my
princess leather face thing again and my
husband I have no idea exciting stuff as
for me I love going to haunted houses
and walkthroughs like that you guys
might have seen the video I did of the
Blum House happy deathday maze on my
channel so Halloween Horror Nights a lot
of fun for me I'm going after the stream
to Six Flags as Fright Fest
and oh yeah I've actually been there
once this year but one of my YouTube
friends his channels Omar be silly he
has like a pass to get me in for free oh
so Jayla and then at the end of the
month my plan my plans were ruined
because my plan was to go back to
Chicago to watch the Cubs in the World
Series but unfortunately that's not
going to happen so I might be going to a
Halloween ball that's taking place here
in LA we have one shout out to give I
did a video on my channel earlier in the
month
called five creepy Japanese death poems
and I did five Japanese death poems
based on some of my favorite horror
anime and I said that whoever could
guess what the five anime were would win
a shout out and a user named Jay bunny
26 was able to guess them all
they were Shiki Death Note another Mirai
Nikki aka future diary and Tokyo ghoul
so I left a link to the channel in the
description so our main story that we're
going to talk about on this episode is
why we have blood here on the show she
ran into a problem with YouTube if you
guys aren't familiar with her channel
she's discusses social commentary and
analyzes trends in horror movies here on
YouTube and she got her channel removed
for no good reason after getting
demonetised
so we've actually got her sub count up
here on the screen and she's been out of
commission for a while and just got her
channel back so if you guys could show
some support we'd love to see that
channel go that number go up throughout
the stream so blood why don't you walk
us through that situation from the
beginning um what happened it's funny
Carrie's here is I had seen a comment
from her asking me to start listing the
movies I talk about each stream so it's
actually starting with the descriptions
to do that and all the sudden my puppet
horror episode has a flag on it which
I've never seen before I had zero
strikes before this goes for those that
don't know the back end of this there is
such a thing as a Community Guidelines
strike and
a copyright strike so all of my stuff
was completely on Community Guidelines
grounds they flagged that I load up my
back up to check because I didn't think
I did anything inappropriate and then by
about halfway through that video is
about an eight minute video I get
another strike on music and horror which
I know for the record like I've had
critical Android on with me and I don't
even think we swore in it so I knew that
100% clean and so I'm going and trying
to get try and file Appeals for all of
these to get them back on and then all
of a sudden a third video gets pulled
and the YouTube role is three stripes
three months you're gone so then it was
a massive Twitter campaign to get me
back so you're actually online when this
all happened you like you were watching
this one floated unfolds in front of
your eyes yep I went from zero strikes
to three strikes terminated in like
about nine minutes that must have been
horrifying oh yeah I would still yeah I
was more or less live tweeting it
because I couldn't wrap my head around
it and I'm just like no I'm clearly
being pranked or there's a troll or
something and they when you submit for
an appeal to get your channel back
they're supposed to have a human being
review it because all they ever gave me
was Community Guidelines strike nothing
beyond on what I violated when they
reviewed my channel they're just like oh
no you know we're keeping you suspended
so that's when we started pushing again
because some point where they claimed
that somebody at YouTube had looked at
your video and decided that it wasn't
okay mm-hmm and I from my understanding
it also is a possibility that they can
put you back and be like okay but these
things need to be 18 plus and there's a
handful of videos expert the line that I
think I could see them wanting that
which is fine I would have lost those
videos to get my channel back wouldn't
been a problem and it was just we were
so beaten down at that point the one I
found out I was reinstated was actually
me
trying to set up another channel like I
was in the process of doing that when I
found out I had come back and it was
just an email saying all right we
reviewed you you're good and I had to
push to somebody else in the community
to get any kind of answer and they're
just like it was a but our bad you're
back that's crazy
typical so do you think that you getting
demonetized on that one video has
something to do with you getting the
strike I would say I got to monetize
probably about 95% of my channel to 98%
of my channel got to monetized a couple
of days before this happened so I
something on the bot flagged me and
without knowing if it was tagged
thumbnail descriptions title any of that
and we I know when brain and I were
talking back and forth she I brought up
the idea of renaming and she's like yeah
we can't roll that out so that's why I'm
becoming after dark analysis so for
those of you who are watching the stream
on demand later right now the channel is
called blood guts in social commentary
but you said on Tuesday you're gonna be
changing it yeah Tuesday I'm putting out
a new trailer and the channel arts gonna
change that I'm slowly going back
through all my content to add new intros
to reflect the change so it's really
unfortunate that you have to like change
your whole identity on YouTube because
of really something that's out of your
control yeah it's it's a cya maneuver
but it's a lot better than building from
the ground up again yeah so are you
gonna have a back-up plan going forward
um I have I was already looking into
other mediums I was completely but
anything as I announced that like the
day before all this happened that I was
looking into other platforms undersea
theory are you talking about other
platforms and they decide to punish you
for it
and I had done a livestream that day
before where I had kind of made fun of
YouTube a little so that everybody's
convinced there
get me very suspect yeah so that video
the one that's they told you was like
there was the one that resulted in your
channel getting taken down that was like
one of the more innocent videos that
you've done right that was the clowns
and gremlins one yeah that was the
things that scared us in childhood
number two and that was a strong about
childhood fears alright so something
just happened in the chat some random
guy literally that's his name some
random guy who posted a chat that says
please sub to blood guts in social
commentary and it got held by review for
my YouTube spot yeah
so which part of the name do you think
it is blood or guts I'm gonna go with
guts maybe yeah can I be both yeah
probably both weird thing is the UM ever
video on my channel currently the
tragedy behind The Twilight Zone movie
which is one of the few instances where
I talk about real death and that one
stayed monetized in everything like that
until I think two three days ago and I
found two other craters that were saying
we think tragedies get now getting
flagged yeah it's actually on there one
of their policies they say we can't let
anyone enable monetization on any form
of tragedy that's why the whole Casey
nice that thing happened where his video
donating to you know the survivors of
the shooting in Texas it couldn't be
monetized at all and he complained he
said no that's our policy
and then when what's his name Jimmy
Fallon oh yeah but [ __ ] to Franco Philip
DeFranco when he didn't tweet and
compared the to ensure an advert it
turned it up at the advert on Jimmy
Fallon's was because they just wanted
the air felt on Jimmy Fallon's
regardless of what was on it right so
yeah they they really don't don't like
tragedy that was one of the things that
was mentioned there was actually an
article written on the website geek
reply about Bloods situation on YouTube
and it's a pretty good article there's a
lot of
misinformation that kind of swells
around about YouTube's processes and
kind of what went on but geek reply
wrote a pretty good article and that was
one of the things they mentioned was the
the whole Casey Neistat controversy and
if you guys want to check in Casey nice
tats video too he did a follow up video
called D monetization D monetization D
monetization where he just kind of
discusses that whole situation and
that's also a pretty good video but for
those who don't know we're talking about
it's actually the Las Vegas incident
that was in question but we won't fault
Mort for not knowing American geography
because I would never I would never be
able to know anything about England
other than London is one of the cities
so what are some of the other tactics
that you're gonna go you're gonna have
going forward to try to protect your
channel I mean that's the thing I'm
keeping my I'm changing my title
unfortunately I don't really want to
change up the title of my videos because
well I'm dealing with fiction I still
don't like the idea of somebody being
able to click on my video or see it and
not know what it's gonna be right so the
D monetization thing I can deal with
because I never made a dime anyway so
that's not really a big difference to me
it's just the removal scare is a little
bunch well it really seems like
YouTube's contradicting themselves
because they say that they don't want to
have these controversial keywords in the
title or the tags or anything so they're
asking people to to change all that so
that so that it's more advertiser
friendly but then they also say that you
you're technically spamming on YouTube
if you don't if the metadata to the
video doesn't accurately represent the
contents of the video and then of course
if you want the video to get discovered
and get seen and picked up by YouTube
systems then you have to play by their
rules and you have to advertise the
video as for the content oh yeah
beginning a lot of that doublespeak I
just had somebody tell me on Twitter
that it sounds like the recommended
thing that keeps coming up for me is my
vomit core video which is one of my top
performing videos you don't see a single
thing but the title is very provocative
and when I use to buddy to tag things
number one tag they always recommend for
me is torture porn because again top
performing video for me and just to be
clear like most of her videos are not
like horrible horribly gory stuff
despite the channel logo most of it's
just like thoughtful analysis on horror
movies and stuff like that yeah I try
and keep violence to a minimum and I
only use still images to just be careful
about copyright because I know they've
done that to a bunch of people how did
you get in touch with YouTube when you
got the channel taken down I got in
touch with them by email and when that
kept failing that's when I started
tagging them on Twitter and that's when
everybody kind of found out and started
brushing them I did encourage people to
do that it was just it was nice that
they did know mm-hmm yeah the whole
community kind of banded together in
that tweet and was tagging at YouTube at
Team YouTube trying to get their
attention and see that they had messed
up I have a creator right now who had
his video removed and isn't sure why I'm
trying to help him through now because
the movie loon was taken off of youtube
and he was like that's my movie I made
it I released it though and they're
giving him Community Guidelines again
Wow
yeah I think in some ways it's kind of
not not cool or good that people are
going through this but we're getting
experience on how to fix it and if
somebody if my channel were suddenly get
taken down I would not know what to do
so I probably turned to you or somebody
who's had this problem before and be
like what do I do and we're getting
training for how to fix things yeah I
mean it is good to see the whole
community banding together like that I
think it's just disappointing that
YouTube black lists everything in the
horror community and then they have to
go and review everything
I'm sure 99.9% the time everything is
absolutely fine so they're just wasting
so much
time energy and money on something which
really shouldn't happen if they think
strategic business they should think
well the whole community is fine and if
something bad is really that bad
someone's gonna flag it so let's just
leave it like that but that's how I
should I yeah I mean I was reading today
they had a blog post and they were
talking about how they were like proud
of their system that it took down these
these videos before it received a single
human flag and I was just thinking I
know how bad their bot is I know like
how many videos have been demonetised
unjustly and I don't think that's
something that they should be proud of
because I'm sure a lot of those videos
were not even in the wrong exactly it's
a bit like our bot is fantastic we love
it it's like yeah it flagged all these
ten videos that were really poorly but
we're not going to tell you about the
400 million videos it flagged
incorrectly and has severely affected us
in many ways and all the other people
you know the create independent creators
but you don't need to know about that
yeah yeah exactly exactly hopefully they
can get that figured out and hopefully
this doesn't happen again
to anyone in the [ __ ] commune or just
anybody who doesn't deserve to get their
channel taken down a lot of people put
tons of hard work into it and it's sad
to see that happening but go ahead and
give some support to blood guts and
social commentary again her link is down
in the description and and also happy
birthday to you blood I think your
birthday's tomorrow right my channels
birthday's tomorrow channels birthday
yeah this all happened right in October
and right around my one-year anniversary
so that was just insult injury on that
yeah so our next topic is devin 7 small
neighbor or a small narrator here in the
community got into a major car wreck and
luckily he seems to be okay he posted a
tweet with some of the photos but it
seems like he has since deleted it so
that was leading me to ask do you guys
have any car crash horror stories that
you want to
I do actually I have a car crash for a
story my family now we're driving
through Italy are just finishing our
holiday and there's a there's a chain of
cars and one car smashes into another
which message into another it's five
cars in this huge chain crash and our
car is the you know the one at the end
so we didn't crash into anyone else
think Philly when we got out of the car
you know to see the damage the the first
car you know the the first car that hit
every other car was absolutely totaled
and there was blood all over the inside
of this shattered windscreen and it was
pretty clear that that guy was he there
you know it wasn't good it wasn't good I
think we were there for about two hours
and the firemen came and they had to get
the I don't even know but these pincer
things to try and tear apart the car to
get the guy out it was just that's
amazing it was horrifying it's
horrifying
so you said you were in Italy was this
your car or a rental car my parents
rental car yeah but so does the
insurance cover that or do you get in
trouble for that oh yeah you have to get
insurance on the car and okay and you
can't rent it without it I think we just
lost the deposit you know what what can
you do it doesn't really matter at least
we weren't debt yeah sure and so you
said the guy that died was the original
one who started the crash yeah he was he
was going way too fast down the highway
and he ended up smashing into someone
else and because the distance they
weren't far enough apart from the other
cars you know one just hit another and
then they hit another in here another
you know no one had enough time to react
which is why it was all five cars and a
sort of Domino mega crash you know the
other four people four cars should I say
well well mostly okay
one guy was driving his boss's brand new
car to man his home
oh I don't know how that turned out but
I would not want to be that guy here's
your car sorry it kind of got destroyed
on the way here but here's what's left
you can't read any better than that so
how long ago was that about 10 years ago
now okay yeah never did find out what
happened to the guy but I'm pretty sure
it it wasn't good yeah I do either of
you ladies have any car crash order
stories to share nothing quite as
devastating is that I've never been in
one but I was able to witness a pretty
horrifying crash which seeing it from a
different point of view is quite
interesting I was hanging out at a
stoplight and right in front of me there
was a sedan sitting in the intersection
waiting to turn left and a truck came
out of nowhere and hit it head-on going
like I don't know 70 miles an hour or
something and it corrupt this poor
little car like a tin can like from
front to back the thing was destroyed
and just seeing it kind of felt like it
was in slow motion seeing it like that
and we got out of there before that
became a huge issue to drive out of
there but I was like I just want to pull
over and get out of my car right now
because I'm horrified that that's gonna
happen to me like you don't want to
drive after seeing something like that
mm-hmm
someone you say truck you don't like a
big like semi-trailer type of thing are
you talking about like an SUV like a
truck car it was like a like one of
those big Ford trucks okay so like the
truck was find a front bumper of it I
think was was ruined but this the sedan
just didn't stand a chance
and yeah why do you have any stories the
it's not so horrifying it's more just
embarrassing I was learning to drive and
my mother decided to screech it from the
side passenger seat for me to turn so I
assumed because she was saying that I
could make the turn into our development
I ended up going over and
taking out a stop sign and yeah they
kind of had to tow me out of there
everybody was fine the car really wasn't
damaged it was just nobody quite figured
out how I got over the embankment
without totally just ripping apart the
axles how long did you just round it for
I didn't really leave the house anyway
so there wasn't really much point in
grounding me that's good so like what
happened with the stop sign did you guys
have to pay for it or what happened with
that you know no it seemed like
everybody kind of thought it was an
accident and since I was only on my
learner's but I wasn't clearly drinking
or anything like that it seemed like all
of it was covered funny thing is it was
in somebody's lawn so I kept knocking on
their door trying to wake them up and it
wasn't until like an hour or so later
they're just like Oh somebody crashed on
our front lawn dead asleep do you need
to be to sleep through a car accident
Yeah right law I don't have any car
crash horror stories I've never
personally been in a car crash but I
have one kind of funny story so it
happened in high school I played
baseball and we had this game and
there's this guy who was supposed to be
giving me a ride home from the game
afterwards and so he had this Jeep and
he said that when we got in the Jeep he
told me that he was like really bad at
backing out of spaces which I don't know
it doesn't really make sense to make us
to me you just kind of go straight back
but so he starts kind of like curving
out of the space and he asks like do I
have room and I was like I'm not really
sure and then he goes back and hits this
car that's parked next to him on the
right and it doesn't damage the car or
anything it just kind of starts shaking
around and he's like oh crap what like
what do I do
and like I looked at the car and it
didn't look like there was any damage to
it and I just told him to go like I
don't think anybody knows that just get
out of here so of course he just floors
it and draws a ton of attention and
everybody turns their heads well it
turns out
like one of the kids on the team and
their parents were a cop or their
parents were a police officer and that
was their car so luckily they were able
to sort it out and I don't think he got
in too much trouble for it but kind of a
funny story um so let's talk about the
master DK Duchess dark dispute so this
is this is probably one of my favorite
stories of the month because it was
instigated by me so it all starts with
Duchess start getting called out in a
tweet by master DK and he says I got
disliked but he's quoting her he says I
like I got just like patted thanks for
the views and then he says I'm not sure
why he says I looked it up in the
dictionary there's no words and how
pathetic that was I mean I'm gonna put
the video that Duchess dark got dislike
bought it on so it's got 7,000 views and
over 900 dislikes in a very short span
of time so clearly it's the work of just
like BOTS so I was wondering why he
posted the screenshot criticizing her
and calling her pathetic without adding
her in the tweet without tagging her so
I said in my response if you're gonna
call someone out don't be a [ __ ] about
it why don't you at Duchess dark hash
spot and he said like oh I didn't really
see the point in tagging her and so
they're just dark appears on the scene
and says like what's pathetic is you
going out of your way to be a dick
towards me so they go in and master DK
posted another tweet about an hour later
saying I had a nice little chat with
Duchess dark about my thoughts on her
dislike bot rant here's our end result
and he posted a picture of Duchess dark
has blocked master DK
what a fool so my question for you guys
is like obviously I was just trolling
and I wanted to see what happened but
should I have called out Duchess dark or
should I have let it should I just let
it go yeah if somebody was talking [ __ ]
about me I would want to know about it
and and I just think that's fair
my logic if someone want to do that you
know I expect my friends to you know put
me in there put me in the loop so I can
defend my work mm-hmm
my logic was that like I don't want to
start conflict in the [ __ ] community
because like we were saying earlier with
blood situation it's awesome when we're
able to band together and accomplish
something like that but like you guys
were saying if there's if there if
someone's getting criticized behind
their back then I also don't think
that's quite right either
right to be fair he did go on to say
that he doesn't think that she's a bad
narrator and I don't think they were
quite on the same page because I don't
think he was suggesting that all of the
dislikes were real but he was proud he
was probably suggesting that a majority
of them were or some of them were and
she took it the wrong way and said like
oh well obviously it's been just like
Baudin but it seems that they were not
able to to figure that dispute out yeah
I find it kind of unnecessary that he
even said anything you know it's like
we're all in the same community doing
the same thing well I put somebody down
yeah is he just is he just a viewer
or is he a creator he is a creator he's
hasn't I think he's kind of fallen off
the map as of late and started doing
like some other types of content he also
had a comment about how like he thinks
that narrator's egos are too big and he
can't wait for the genre to dry up and
but like oh why
I mean it seems like he is still doing
some narrations from time to time but
that's not all of his content anymore
hope he's not doing it anymore then
what's his problem with us right I mean
I guess they might be a little bit
jealous that he's doing a little bit
better than oh yeah that's that stuff is
just reinforcing to the community that
it's like it like I said earlier it's
not a zero-sum game we can all have the
same subscribers it's not like well if
you get a sub I don't get a sub yeah so
that there's never been a point in
fighting obviously you're gonna meet
people that rub you the wrong way but
why start unnecessary drama within the
community when we have enough drama from
YouTube yeah I was just like it's
frustrating to see them fighting about
something small like that when we have
major issues in the community that we
should be talking about anyways it seems
that our time has come but don't worry
because we're gonna be doing new dead
streams every month the next stream will
be November 25th at 2 p.m. Pacific
that's F p.m. Eastern and 10 p.m. GMT
[Music]
the best place to catch us is live on
the cz World channel but if you missed
it we're also on demand on YouTube
iTunes and Google Play if you have a
story you'd like us to read here in the
show or if you find any news about going
on around the YouTube for community that
we might be able to talk about send an
email to Susie's world at gmail.com
the music in the dead stream is composed
by OST maker visit his link in the
description and go ahead and subscribe
to OST makers channel for some more
great Qin's rabbit where can the people
find you on social media and find me on
Facebook and Twitter just searching lady
white rabbit and now also on soundcloud
and Moritz where can they find your
links you can you can go on Instagram or
Twitter pretty pretty good places at the
mortis media if easy enough and blood
and now that you are back online where
can our fans go to check out your
channel all my social medias linked in
the about page on my channel but I'm on
Facebook Twitter Instagram all under
blood guts SC all one word and are you
gonna be changing that after Tuesday I
will spend upon you yeah I'm not sure if
I can change on handles like that but um
yeah everything will be after dark
analysis as of Tuesday and you can find
you'll find people to find the links on
here YouTube if you're having trouble
finding it you can find me on Facebook
Google+ and Instagram as C's world my
twitter handle is Suzie's world
underscore or remember to subscribe to
seize these world for new Horrors every
week bring that death bell for
notifications and we'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]